Marvel Comics hasn't always been as big
as it is today and not all of the
company's history is as heroic as The
Adventures of spider-man or Captain
America since starting out as timely
comics in 1939 they've created countless
classics but they've also done a few
things they probably wish we'd forget
here are a few of Marvel's biggest
misstep s-- atlas distribution disaster
back in the 1950s when Marvel was still
called Atlas comics publisher Martin
Goodman decided to outsource
distribution one problem the
distribution company almost immediately
went bankrupt leaving Goodman no option
but to ask archrival DC to distribute
his books DC put the screws to Atlas
limiting them to only eight comics a
month a huge drop from the 60 or so
titles Atlas had previously published
not only did profits plunge but Atlas
had to fire almost all of their artists
and writers there was simply nothing for
them to do ironically the company
survived because of an editorial
oversight by Stan Lee for years he had
been buying too many stories from his
creators ending up with a closet full of
unpublished comics when Atlas imploded
they were able to stay afloat by finally
publishing the issues Stan had
accidently stockpiled tossing pages
before comics were seen as collectibles
original comic art was a means to an end
it was photographed colored printed and
then the originals were discarded while
some original pages have been preserved
by collectors Marvel spent decades
simply chucking countless others not
unlike the way the BBC tossed dozens of
early Doctor Who episodes today finding
a missing comic page is a victory for
both collectors and comics historians
creator mistreatment it's a sad fact
that while Marvel rakes in billions of
dollars worldwide with their films the
creators often see little or no money
from it thanks to work for hire
contracts that sign all the rights away
one of the worst examples of Marvel's
questionable treatment of their creators
is the case of Gary Friedrich the
co-creator of Ghost Rider after the
Ghost Rider movies came out Friedrich
took Marvel to court for compensation
related to merchandising not only did he
lose the lawsuit Marvel counter sued for
$17,000 and forced him to stop selling
anything ghostwriter related at
conventions a judge later overturned the
decision and both parties settled out of
court
Royale Roy
for a period Marvel Comics also
published star comics label dedicated to
animated tie-ins like Thundercats and
Fraggle Rock and other kid-friendly fare
part of stars approach was to copy the
success of Harvey comics they did a
little too well though royal Roy a young
millionaire was basically an exact copy
of Harvey's Richie Rich and was actually
created by an ex Harvey employee Harvey
sued Marvel for infringing on their
property and royal Roy was cancelled
after a handful of issues Ron Pearlman
in January of 1989 Ron Perelman bought
Marvel for just over 82 million dollars
he then went full-on wolf of Wall Street
using Marvel as collateral to leverage
the purchase of other trading card comic
book and toy companies sending the
company 700 million dollars into death
by the time pro man's reign ended the
company had declared bankruptcy over a
third of its employees had been laid off
and the entire comic book industry had
collapsed and Pearlman while he got rich
off of it all with an estimated net
worth of 14 billion dollars sometimes
the super villains win film rights in
the early 90s cash-strapped Marvel
raised capital by signing away the film
rights to pretty much all their
characters for pennies on the dollar
it seems short-sighted but it almost
makes sense given that every Marvel film
prior to 1998 blade was a failure don't
remember those films there's a good
reason for that first there was a 1990
direct-to-video version of Captain
America which reported profits of just
over 10 thousand dollars on a 10 million
dollar budget
then four years later the first
Fantastic Four was produced on a
shoestring just so a small movie studio
could legally retain the rights to the
characters it was so bad Marvel ended up
spending millions of dollars to keep the
film from being distributed in order to
save the brand from being cheapened by a
low-budget flop Marvel learned their
lesson though and in 2004 they formed
their own studio and began buying back
the rights to their characters so they
can make the movies themselves seems
like that move worked out pretty well
Marvel's image in 1992 several of
Marvel's top creators went to their
bosses and asked for a better deal more
money per page more royalties for
characters they created and a more fair
portion of what Marvel was earning off
of their work Marvel told them to pounce
and in response the artists quit Marvel
and form their own company Image Comics
they became super stars an image went on
to revolutionize the industry while
Marvel stock dropped so sharply it was
featured on an episode of money line
Marvel survived but they could have
stayed ahead of the game and saved
themselves a lot of trouble just by
playing fair guiding light in 2006
Marvel's editor-in-chief Joe Quesada
thought it would be a great idea to
partner with of all companies Procter &
Gamble mostly known for selling Pringles
creating the bowel loosening food
additive olestra and producing the soap
opera guiding light to that end guiding
light aired an episode in which a
longtime character was shocked by some
Halloween decorations and briefly gained
superpowers Marvel wrote their own
version of the story as a six-page mini
crossover the hope was that the
cross-promotion would encourage soap
viewers and comics fans to walk on the
other side but not many did and guiding
light only lasted a few more years
before it was canceled
dang thanks for watching subscribe to
our YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which Marvel
mistake you think was the worst